the doctor may obtain a
skin biopsy to view the tissue under a
microscope and diagnose
your condition the skin is the largest organ in
the body and is responsible for
regulating body temperature sensing
painful and pleasurable stimuli
providing a protective barrier
against  bacteria
toxins
and by preventing the evaporation of internal fluid
the skin consists of three layers the
epidermis the dermis and the hypodermis the
epidermis helps prevent
most bacteria and other
foreign substances from entering the body
the dermis provides support to the
epidermis and  gives the skin
suppleness and toughness the hypodermis is
the layer of fat cells that
provides insulation and protective support
skin biopsies are
commonly ordered for warts and moles
skin cancers and other growths
allergic reactions
bacterial and fungal infections acne psoriasis and
lesions and  scars for all
bio procedures  skin psias the
doctor will inject a local anesthetic into the
skin to numb the
area shave biopsies are
usually done on superficial lesions
during this procedure
the doctor will use a sharp scalpel or
razor blade to finely cut or
shave off the top layer of skin  the
skin lesion this type of biopsy does not require
stitches doctors usually
perform a needle biopsy for
deeper skin lesions
the doctor will rotate a circular
, hollow scalpel around the lesion until
completely cutting through the
epidermis and dermis
he  or she will remove a small cylinder
of skin usually smaller than
the size of a pencil sharpener containing
all the skin layers and the lesion
depending on the size of the sample the area
may or may not be stitched closed
an exceptional biopsy is larger  and
deep that a biopsy by scraping or
puncture is performed in conditions such
as cancer which must be extracted in
the doctor will go as
deep as necessary to remove the
entire visibly affected area
as well as some unaffected
tissue surrounding the outside of the lesion
the incision is then closed with
stitches
after the biopsy you will need to
keep the area dry and covered  with a
sterile bandage or gauze for a day or two
an antibiotic ointment should be applied
until the area is completely
healed acetaminophen or ibuprofen can be taken
for any
pain in the biopsy area